Mary starts off this hour in New York
City hi Mary how are you hi mr. Ramsey
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up well to make a very long
story short when I was 20 years old I
found myself dropping out of college
pregnant and in a very abusive
relationship and I decided that I didn't
want to live this way and I you know I
have to pull myself up and I learned the
hard way through the legal system that
no one else is gonna help me about
myself so I pulled myself together I
hired an attorney I went back to school
and I ended up graduating with my
bachelor's second in my class good for
you and more than a lawyer I'm actually
just taking my LSAT now I plan to go to
law school soon yeah I suspect I suspect
I want you as my lawyer where paternity
issues are up you might be on a dadgum
crusade that's my plan now I realized no
one's gonna help me but myself so I
recently I'm not in a terrible amount of
debt but because of you know the way the
relationship ended and hospital bills
that I was left with and stuff from my
pregnancy I had to you know use my
credit card so I'm not too bad I'm only
about eight thousand dollars in credit
card debt which doesn't scare me because
I know I can handle that but I also have
about thirty eight thousand in student
loan debt and I would really like to get
that taken care of and start my baby
steps and I already have a thousand in
the bank so really the next thing is
baby steps that my problem is budgeting
because I'm a bartender so my income
varies like dramatically I can make $80
one week or you know $1,100 the next
week so it's so dramatically different
and with my lawyer fees and court fees
and random costs my expenses are
different from month to month so I'm
just trying to understand getting a
handle on what to do and how to do it
properly and not be cash-poor just to
pay my debts off so how are you I'm
sorry how old are you
I'm 24 just 24 man you're gettin after
it proud of you well done well done yeah
nothing gonna keep you down you're gonna
be all right um your scrapper so how you
paying for Law School
I haven't gotten that far yet okay I
just took the LSAT again so I'm applying
to schools now and I'm working on that
and the other thing is I live in New
York but I'm hoping to move to Virginia
or DC to go to law school which is a
whole nother feat with the legal matter
and being allowed to do that and
everything but that would really be
great but as you know as far as moving
goes that's another expense I have to
save for so all these random things I'm
trying to save for and my car has almost
three two thousand miles I need new cars
all these random things I feel
overwhelmed with how to separate them
all exactly all right well we're going
to do the same thing with both items or
with all items rather we're simply going
to do a prioritized spending plan you
ever done a to-do list where you just
made out a list of random things and
then you rewrote it in order of most
important at least important yes so you
do the most important thing first and
early in the day and then you work your
way through down to the least important
thing if you get all the way through
that that's what we're going to do with
the money okay and so we're gonna say
the very first thing every week that you
buy is food if nothing else happens
you're gonna buy food okay the next
thing you're gonna do is keep your
lights and water on okay the next thing
you're gonna do is pay your rent food
shelter clothing transportation
utilities long before all these other
things that are flying around that we're
worrying about discussing here but
you're gonna put them on the list
they're just you're gonna eat and keep
the lights on first okay and by the way
you make enough money probably most
weeks to do more than necessities but
we're gonna put the necessities first so
we're gonna make a list of everything
that you want to do with money replace
the car go to law school pay off the
$8,000 pay off the $38,000 move to
Washington DC whatever we need to do
with money I'm gonna make a list of all
of those things monthly expenses and big
items that we're trying to get ready for
right or knock the credit cards out or
whatever we're going to do medical bills
or legal bills or whatever right and
you're gonna make a list most important
to least important and nothing goes on
the list until you've knocked out food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities and the sucess ''tis our first
okay but then you just go down the list
and go okay right now paying this law
lawyer bill is this week
our this month is more important than
saving for a car what you probably is or
make it saving up some money to make
this move now that I've got accepted to
law school and I got a full scholarship
as a single mom what you might then
that's gonna you know that's gonna be
pretty high on the list when that
happens but probably this week it's not
you know and saying you're gonna do a
new list every week and your priorities
will change from week to week month to
month but you're gonna do a new list
every week and you'll update the old one
just keep it on a you know a simple word
document is fine if you want to or you
can use every dollar some people use
every dollar to do it but but it's a
prioritized spending plan from most
important to least important here's what
will happen once you lay all of that out
you're not going to accept an $80 week
anymore because you're gonna be looking
at it going I gotta make more than that
you guys aren't gonna give me hours I
gotta get something else okay
and you're gonna have 1,100 ollar weeks
lots of them because once you've got
your needs and your wants and your
dreams all prioritize that on paper that
becomes a goal by the very nature of it
and you get fired up and going I'm
scrapping my way through this like all
this other stuff you scrapped your way
through you're a rock star kiddo hold on
I'm gonna send you a copy of the Total
Money Makeover book to help you do all
of this it's got a form in the back
called the irregular income planning
sheet that will outline exactly what I
just told you this is the Dave Ramsey
show